[Applause]
[Music]
again I want to point out that some
son-of-a-bitch on this staff shot that
using someone else's body
that is not
I complain about this every single time
they went out and found someone they
just made it I don't know that's an
intern and then they put my face on the
guy I'm not happy I'm not happy I don't
stand like that that's not I think you
look good I don't stand like this in
that thing you look like a gammon
fashion model yeah I do
you know all right well we're gonna
start for example I was watching
Antiques Roadshow you'll know the show
Antiques Roadshow yeah what's in that
show I want to know what's going on so I
hit the button and it said money-hungry
Desperados pawn off the belongings of
relatives who have been dead for about
an hour yeah I was watching I was
watching the show Fox and Friends
yeah he's watching Fox and Friends then
I hit the button and it said here the
president's next tweet seconds before he
sends it up watching stranger things the
show stranger
then I hit the button and it said the
kids from all those award shows finally
get their own series Dateline
I was watching Dateline and then I hit
the button and it said forensic
investigators tell you all the poisons
there Labs are unable to detect and the
best websites to buy them
it's a new show called 911 911 yeah yeah
and then I hit the button and said if
this show we're realistic it would be
90% elderly people calling and asking
where to recycle broken space heaters
crazy ex-girlfriend I was watching crazy
ex-girlfriend yeah people love that show
and then I hit the button and it said I
thought this show would be about Brenda
but it's not
keep your distance Brenda PS I miss you
he's writing these things anyway I was
watching this is us so I was watching
the show this is us yeah then I hit the
button it said sorry but unless you're
incredibly attractive this is just them
Vikings I was watching Vikings
yeah the show Vikings yeah but I hit the
button and it said reddit in real life
then finally I was watching Dancing with
the Stars yeah and then I hit the button
said how today's celebrities go toward
the light
[Applause]
you